[Musique]
la bouteille
puis bonjour allait bien
gilles marsan ramasse les bouteilles
depuis qu'il a 15 ans tous les jours il
fait le tour des boutiques et leurs
droits qu'ils préfèrent c'est le petit
marché de sa dette
c'est
on connaît depuis combien de temps il
fait ça
comme l a dit gilles raconte à 10 81
la cadence
[Musique]
mais et roula pas et 10 des plus tendues
à cause ou fait ça
il a donné son aval
gilles n'a jamais eu un vrai travail
mais toute sa vie il n'a pas arrêté de
faire des petits boulots de donner un
coup de main à gauche à droite aux
marchands et aux bazardiers collait bien
à web est alors aujourd'hui chacun lui
refile quelques fruits quelques légumes
[Musique]
mater travail
m
je suis à paris at il dit
red bull et gilles tout le monde est
gentil
au petit marché même le boucher se
souvient quand gilles était barman
non
par des médias matin
à l'époque c'était comme ça
elles sont allées
je n'y vais nettoyer
merci à tous
et comme j les blagueurs madame c'est
souvent son anniversaire
pièce fuite alors jacobacci j'y venais
avec son vélo et mettez
enfin sachez écouter mon vélo à 5h ce
matin le soir quand vanille trouver un
nom
oui
bt dieu mais l'abitibienne
et la raison voilà ce qu'est ce qu'ils
ont sur le chemin du retour
gilles s'arrête encore dans l'un ou
l'autre gisements allez encore une
petite dizaine de bouteilles ça suffira
pour aujourd'hui
monsieur
c'est avec deux sacs garantie qu il
arrive au pied de son immeuble dans le
quartier mes patates à durand et ses
dangers petit cagibi qu'ils entreposent
son trésor
[Musique]
urmatt ou non la boulimique tort
[Applaudissements]
quel coach des bouteilles ou stock dès
leur seconde balle ballif combien de
bouteilles sur man 3 oui je veux encore
mon trésor met en bouteille n'guemo
la tête
un couteau à la main collée par mois
nico tu pas mal pas mal et j'ai moins de
temps et après que ça vous fait après à
qui vous répondent
la commission des prix c'est quoi son
nom
day
valérie bouteille allô bonjour
une fois par mois environ
gilles fait appel à une des neuf
sociétés de collecte du département
ce sont ces connecteurs qui met les
bouteilles sur palettes et les
rapportent aux brasseries de bourbon à
saint denis
selon les brasseries 70% des bouteilles
mises en vente dans l'île sont ainsi
récupérer 40 millions de bouteilles par
an plus de cent mille bouteilles par
jour
[Musique]
les brasseries de bourbon ne souhaite
pas communiquer le prix payé pour les
bouteilles mais grâce à ce circuit de
recyclage
elle affirme réinjecter chaque année
dans l'économie locale
près de trois millions d'euros gilles
lui appelle le connecteur quand il a
ramassé 4 à 5000 bouteilles soit 30 à 40
grands sacs
0,6 c'est pas mal
c'est à peu près combien chaque mois
les
on voit même blanc voir qu'il reste des
dents
ce montant est bon et bilan est bon
[Musique]
qui
ce cas quel adversaire
avocate au 1000 m à
quand on lui demande quel est son rêve
gilles dit qu'il aimerait prendre
l'avion pour aller voir sa fille qui vit
dans l'hexagone pour payer le billet 700
euros on a calculé
il lui reste juste à ramasser quatorze
mille bouteilles gilles retrouve wii